it seems like just the other day that
america's self-described moral leaders
were denouncing us for pointing out the
obvious
democrats are intentionally accelerating
demographic change in this country for
political advantage so rather than
convince people to vote for them that's
called democracy they're counting on
brand new voters that's what we said on
the show immediately after we said that
they became completely hysterical they
tried to pull us off the air they said
we were espousing something called the
great replacement theory a well-known
racist fantasy right in other words shut
up
and then this week the new census
numbers came out here's what those
numbers show the number not the
proportion but the absolute number of
americans who describe themselves as
white has dropped for the first time in
our history since the census began back
in 1890 the total decline is around 5
million people now that is huge
experts who study demographics for a
living were shocked by it they'd never
seen anything like this
why did this happen where did all these
people go and why they're americans
remember
well as leading democrats put it again
and again who cares fewer white people
in america is a great thing and we
should celebrate
right now stephen miller and donald
trump are at mar-a-lago and they're
throwing up because this is not the
america they want to see i was at the
white house the other day and guess
who's got stephen miller's old office
her name is susan rice
and she's one of us and guess who is in
ivanka trump's old office julie
rodriguez who she is he's our child i
love julie granddaughter
did you hear that her name is susan rice
she's one of us
meaning she's a democrat no
it means she's not white us is the
non-white people cheering the extinction
of white people that was on television
think about that for a minute it's hard
to think about it actually because it's
that evil and if you wanted to encourage
permanent racial division maybe even
violence in america that is exactly how
you would talk on television these
people are completely out of control
they are dangerous it's not just cnn
analysts who are talking this way by the
way once again there is no more divisive
thing that you could say on television
there's no way you could more quickly
and more permanently wreck the country
than to encourage people to gloat over
the decline of a race seriously imagine
any other race
people talking like that it's nuts
actually
but again members of congress are
talking that way or even fake ones
here's eleanor holmes norton who
pretends to serve in congress
look at where the population is and
that's how we win
or have to try to win in the census
numbers because the population growth
has been in the cities
and in the suburbs among minorities
and that's what gives us some leverage
got that democrats win when we have
fewer white people in the country and
that's why they're celebrating the new
census number she just said that out
loud
you should never say anything like that
out loud but they are at the washington
post columnist jennifer rubin joined the
cheering fewer white people she wrote
you can look it up is quote fabulous
news
now we need to prevent minority white
rule
naughty white rule do you recognize that
phrase oh south africa that's what she
wants south africa
she said it we didn't we would never say
something like that but wait a second
you ask what about the numbers what
happened to all those white people who
are now missing from the census well it
turns out many of them perished in the
opioid epidemic hundreds of thousands of
young americans mostly from rural
communities dead from drug overdoses
a columnist from the washington post is
cheering that their deaths are fabulous
she says
it's hard even to know how to respond to
that
so we're going to pull back and let
pedro gonzalez assess that he's
associated at chronicles magazine we're
happy to have him join us now pedro
thanks so much for coming on boy if you
wanted to wreck the united states and
cause actual conflict you would talk
like jen rubin what why are they talking
this way
because this is about power and control
and the the funny thing about the reuben
narrative is basically
uh
white people are being marginalized but
you're not allowed to notice
you're not even allowed to talk about it
and if you disagree with them being
marginalized you're racist
it's racist of course because supposedly
white people are the villains of human
history that is an absurd calumny the
truth is that the specter of white
supremacy is used to fuel the growth of
a corrupt political order and whites are
in fact the victims in this system
if you look at things like wages and
life expectancy those have fallen for
the white working class while they've
risen for all other groups if you look
at our culture of affirmative action we
disadvantage white people in this
country in jobs and schooling and we do
it by lowering expectations and
standards for everyone else deaths
related to suicide and as you noted drug
overdoses alcohol-related illnesses
these things have soared from
middle-aged white men and women in the
last 20 years and people like jennifer
rubin can do little then say you deserve
it i'm going to spit on your grave and
you're not allowed to notice or do
anything about it
all of this is the result of deliberate
policy choices not from the democratic
party it's also a republican party
problem the unit party is a real thing
the ruling class in this country has
deconstructed the nation it was
entrusted to govern
it invited millions of people into this
country and told them that any disparity
in outcome you just point to a white
person and say it's your fault
it's psychotic but historically this is
what imperial and colonial governments
do they encourage division between
groups in other words making people hate
each other is the point the the
neo-liberal politics of racial
grievances of demographic deconstruction
are about poisoning the moral character
of americans and making them so hateful
toward each other that they don't notice
people like reuben and they don't notice
people like the uniparty are actively
trying to destroy
i think their lives
to stop talking about race entirely in
this country and just talk about
americans i mean
hundreds of thousands of americans
living aside their color have died of
opioid ods and the only one anyone in
washington notices is george floyd so
how
do you think americans feel about that
if your nephew or your son just died at
22 of an opioid od and jennifer rubin
says that's great news
like you're gonna get something horrible
if you keep acting that way aren't you
yeah no it's fundamentally dehumanizing
you're completely stripping people of
the thing that makes them human and
basically just reducing them to points
on a board the fewer white people in
this country like you said is a good
thing and again if you're a white person
and you hear this what is your reaction
going to be
and
you're basically stoking there i mean
there's no there's no way to put this
nicely right you're ginning up racial
hatred between different groups in this
country that might otherwise get along
and you're doing it for either cynical
or ideological reasons i'm not sure
which is worse whether you really
believe in this stuff or it's just a
means to an end in either case it is
anti-civilizational if this if you want
to destroy a society this is how you do
it exactly and they're going to make
people super radical and it's going to
be gen ruben's fault there's no doubt
about that
pedro gonzalez i appreciate it thank you
so much
thanks for having me
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else